so here's an idea if someone is 18 years
old and does not have a job and wants to
borrow tens of thousands of dollars do
you know what lenders tell them no
you're 18 years old you don't have a job
we're not going to loan you 50 or 60 or
$80,000 that's the answer no well along
come our brilliant federal government
and says oh will guarantee juniors loan
if junior is stupid and doesn't graduate
52 percent of people that start college
graduate by the way 48 percent don't but
they all that take out a student loan
leave their graduation paper or not
diploma or not with the student loan
debt we the federal government are going
to guarantee little Junior why because
we want to encourage education well the
net result has not been encouraged
education 52% is all the graduate
the net result has been a whole bunch of
people with debt guaranteed by the
government add the stats in this article
to it you know what you've got Grandma
and Grandpa also guaranteed it they
co-signed for it Parent PLUS loans mommy
and daddy co-signed for junior because
for whatever reason junior couldn't get
the loan on his own so what do you do
grandpa come on if a little little
precious little grandbaby comes and I
got precious little grandbabies if they
come trotting in at 18 years old and
asking for student loans my answer will
be no I might be able to give them some
money and help them but I will not be
signing for any loans and I will not be
giving them any money if they're going
to be borrowing money I will not
participate in their stupidity in their
delusional exercise well you can't go to
school without alone everybody
is that except all these young people
that I meet that are doing it well not
everybody's parents are rich really I
mean looser language people seriously
okay let's look the average in-state
tuition you can pay for if you work 20
to 30 hours a week babysitting
dog walking cutting grass you can't do
it on minimum wage but those three
things you can make fifteen to twenty
dollars an hour you can get through
school but your college choice cannot be
some school you can't afford so by the
way you shouldn't buy a Mercedes if
you're a broke person that's stupid so
you don't go to a school you can't
afford if you're a broke person you go
to n state tuition you go to Community
College for the first couple years and
get your basics knocked out of the way
they cost even a lot even half or a
third of what in-state tuition costs so
mommy and daddy instead of participating
in this ridiculous stupidity and then
waddling your fat butt into your 60s
broke in with your kids student loan
debt around your neck instead of doing
that why don't you say no choose a
school you can afford and I'll help you
get a job and I'll take an extra job and
give you some money I'll sell some stuff
and give you some money but quit
participating in this idea that all
education requires borrowing to get
through it's simply mathematically not
true so what I'm saying is is we do not
have a student loan crisis in America we
have a parenting crisis and we're stupid
about education how oxymoronic is that
we are stupid about education people go
30 40 50 60 $80,000 in debt to get a
masters degree in German polka history
give me a break absolutely useless
education in the marketplace Rachel
always says left handed puppetry you
know
as if right-handed puppetry had a real
marketplace but anyway you're going to
go get a degree that you do not have a
way to earn a living and go tens of
thousands $100,000 $80,000 $60,000 in
debt to do that and mom and dad you just
stand there and watch them and go yeah I
won't you study something stupid at a
college you can't afford and then we're
all going to stand back and watch you
wreck your life instead of intervening
as if they had a drug problem
that's how stringently I would intervene
they're a team they can make their
choices they're 18 they can be a coke
addict too but I'm going to love them
enough to get all up in their life and
make their life miserable until they
quit that stuff and the same thing is
going to be true if they try to go to a
college they can't afford to study
something stupid that does not allow
them to make a living which is the first
purpose of Education and the
justification that everybody uses to go
into debt to get it so choose a college
you can afford have a plan to work while
you're there no mom and dad and grandpa
and grandma we're not going to co-sign
and you're going to walk up next to this
18-year old some of which some of them
have some sense but some of them hadn't
got a brain enough to go to college
because they're the stuff the choices
they're making I talked to one the other
day is going to go to college you know
why she liked the college out-of-state
tuition which is over double what our
in-state would be at another state
college very similar level of education
you know why she wanted to go there
because it was a nice town see people
like that should not be allowed to make
decisions by themselves they're not
grownups
that's a dumb but statement isn't it and
if you're her mama you're her daddy
you're her grandpa you're her granny you
co-signed for the loan years dumb a but
as she is and then we end up with 73% of
older student loan borrowers having
borrowed money for someone else to go to
school and it's quadrupled in just the
last decade the stupidity is it's alive
and well stop at America stop it
this is the Dave Ramsey show hey guys
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video click the subscribe button to get
the latest content and check out these
other great clips from the show
[Music]